يزور الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديميرسيلنسكي
واشنطن في اول جوله خارجيه له منذ بدء حرب
روسيا على بلاده تتضمن زياره منح الولايات
المتحده مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا
تتضمن منظومه صواريخ فاتوره وفي ظل
استمرار للقتال بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه قال بوتن ان استمرار الغرب في
تصليح كير يقود فرص السلام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات هل تحمل زياره زينسكي
الى واشنطن في طياتها رسائل تصعيد ام فرص
الممكنه لتسويه النزاع
وكيف نقرا خطابه وزير الدفاع والتلويح
بالقدرات والاستعدادات النوويه الروسيه
والاعلان عن نشر منظومات الصاروخيه
العابره للقارات
وثالثا ما هي مقالات الصراع الغربي الروسي
في ضوء الرسائل المتبادله بين طرفين وما
مخاطر اتساع نطاقه على السلم العالمي
[موسيقى]
اذا زياره هي الاولى منذ اندلاع الغرب
الحرب وتتضمن لقاءات في القمه مع قياده
الامريكيه وخطابا امام الكونجرس وربما
يكون الاهم بالنسبه للرئيس الاوكراني
هو ان يعود من حيث اتى محملا بالسله من
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه الثمينه
والنوعيه ضمن حزمه يقال انها تكلفتها تبلغ
خمسه واربعين مليار دولار
الحديث هنا عن عده انواع من الاسلحه
تتقدمها منظومه صواريخ باتريات ذائعه
الصيد والتي تهدد موسكو بالرد بيقسوه
وحزما على اي جهه تستلمها وتستخدمها داخل
اوكرانيا تطورات تراجعت في ظلها فرص
السلام لتترك المكانه لخطط التسلح
والتقارير الحربيات كتلك التي تلقاها بوتر
من قياداتها العسكريه وجعلته يقطع من جديد
بان الغرب كل ما يريده اضعاف روسيا تمهيدا
لتفتيتها وتلك رؤيه تعبر عن ابعاد عميقه
وخطيره في حرب لا تلوح لها نهايه حتى الان
استبق زيارته الى الولايات المتحده
بتغريده قال فيها انه ذاهب للولايات
المتحده لبحث التعاون بينك وواشنطن وتعزيز
القدرات الدفاعيه للجيش الاوكراني
تتزامنوا الزياره ومرور 300 يوما على
اندلاع حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض قالت ان
الزياره تاتي تلبيه لدعوه من الرئيس بيضا
للتاكيد على الالتزام بدعم اوكرانيا امنيا
واقتصاديا وانسانيا مهما استغرق ذلك من
وقت وكشف مسؤول رفيع في الاداره الامريكيه
ان بيدن سيعلن عن حزمه مساعدات جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليارين دولار تتضمن
صواريخ باتريات وقنابل دقيقه
انا المسؤول الامريكي قال ايضا
مباشره مع روسيا وكل ما تفعله هو دعم
الشعب الاوكراني
مضيفا ان روسيا لم تظهر حتى الان اي نيه
للانسحابي من اوكرانيا ولم تظهر اي مؤشر
لانهاء الحرب بشكل منصف
في اول تعليق على الزياره قال الكريملين
انه لا توجد لدى روسيا توقعات ايجابيه من
زياره الرئيس الاوكراني الى واشنطن
انه لا يتوقع تغيرا في موقف كيف بشان
مفاوضات السلام بعد زياره زنسكي للولايات
المتحده
حذر الكرملين كذلك من ان التسليم اسلحه
امريكيه جديده الى اوكرانيا سيؤدي الى
تفاقم الصراع ولا يبشر بالخير باوكرانيا
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين قال خلال اجتماعي
نهايه العام مع قاده وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان حلف الناتو يستخدم قدراته كامله ضد
روسيا وهي تعلم بكل المعطيات بهذا الشان
وتعهد بان تحقق بلاده جميع اهدافها
العسكريه في اوكرانيا وان تحافظ على توازن
الرد النووي الذي وصفه بانه اساسه
الاستقرار في العالم كما اكد مواصله دعم
القدرات النوويه الروسيه وزياده القوه
الاستراتيجيه في جميع الاسلحه الحديثه مثل
صواريخ صار مارتنر التي قال انه لا مثيل
لها في العالم
[موسيقى]
هواري مناقشته هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو
وفجيني فدراف عضو مجلس الدومه الروسي ومن
واشنطن جون هيرتس مسؤول شؤون اراسيا في
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه والسفير
الامريكي السابق لدى اوكرانيا ضيفيني
العزيزين شكرا جزيلا لوجودكم معنا في ما
وراء الخبر وابدا معك السيد جون هيرتس
الان
يتوجه الى واشنطن ويتوقع ان يحمل المزيد
من الاسلحه النوعيه والمساعدات ويعود بها
الى كيف
هل هذا ما تحتاجه الحرب في هذه المرحله
لتمنع الناس من حصول على الكهرباء
الروسيه والايرانيه وبالتالي هم يحتاجون
مثل هذا السلاح
ولكن في النهايه يا سيد في دروس يعني هذا
هو الطبيعي هناك مساران للحرب مسار يسعى
للحصول على المزيد من الاسلحه و اييي
ابداء القوه ومسار يبحث عن فرص السلام اذا
ما هي المشكله في هذه الزياره
الدولي اوكرانيا لم تكن موجوده بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لذلك هذه المناطق هي غير
قانونيه وخرجت من
الاتحاد السوفيتي بشكل غير قانوني نحن
مستعدين للاتفاق ولكن على اساس واعتمادا
على القانون الدولي وهذا ما تحدثنا عنه في
العام السابق اذا كل المناطق الاوكرانيه
المتنازع المتنازع عليها والخلاف فيه ممكن
ان نقرر ان لا انه هاجم هذه المناطق بشرط
ان لا يكون هناك اي تهديدات من قبل
على هذه الاراضي والمناطق نحن نحن همم
نحترم اوكرانيا والقوانين الدوليه ولكن
القوه الغربيه تريد ان تزيد الازمه
ولانه هناك دوله ثاني فقط لا يستطيعون ان
يخسروا اي حرب هي امريكا وروسيا
لذلك كل ما تقوم امريكا باطاله امد هذه
الحرب كل ما هم يقوم باطرار روسيا
لاستخدام القوه النوويه انتم تعلمون اذا
قامت روسيا بتفعيل هذه الاله عندها سوف
تبتعد الولايات المتحده عن الاذاعه
الاوكراني وعندها سوف يخسرون
لا تضع امامها هذا الهدف ولكن الولايات
المتحده تضعنا في موقف يجبرنا على هذا
الموقف وهذا غلط من
جانبهم اذا التورط الامريكي في هذا النزاع
داخلي حيث نحاول اعاده النظام والقانون
على مناطق تابعه لنا هذا ما يقوم به
الولايات المتحده
على اكثر من مستوى لكن انا اريد ان اعود
حديث او موضوع الزياره الان في النهايه
همم سيذهبس
بايدن داعزنسكيلي كي يزور واشنطن
وزنسكي سيخاطب
الكونجرس بشقيه
وكذلك سيخاطب الراي العام الامريكي
والسؤال هل الشرائح كلها
داخل الولايات المتحده على قلب رجل واحد
فيما يتعلق بموضوع اوكرانيا والمساعده لها
اكثر من 70% من الشعب الامريكي يدعم تقديم
مساعداتهم قويه لاقراء للايقاف العدوان
الروسي والرئيسكي زيارته هذه سيزيد من هذا
الدعم لان الشعب الامريكي يفهم ان مسقط
سنه حرب من غير انسانيه على اوكرانيا
وصديقي من وسط انا زميلي وليس صديقي قدم
الكثير معلومات المضله ما يجري روسيا
تخالف القانون الدولي
وتطلق حربا غير ضد اوكرانيا وتستولي
في الجزائر
والاطفال
يقولون ان هذه الحرب امريكا
في الدفاع عن ارضه ضد العدوان الروسي لان
هدف روسي هو تدمير اوكرانيا وهذا امر غير
مقود
وفي النهايه همم السيد فدراس هذا ما تقوله
واشنطن واشنطن تقول انها لا تريد ان تتدخل
تريد فقط ان تساعد الطرف في هذه الحرب ما
هي رسائل التي تتلقاها موسكو في المقابل
من هذه الزياره ما الذي يقلقها ما الذي
يستفزها بهذه الصوره
نحن ننظر لهذه الزياره خطا من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه لان ما تتدخل به الاداره
الامريكيه هو النزاع ليس نضاعهم
لذلك نعم فعلا تقول ان الشعب الامريكي
يدعم هذه الدعم ولكن هل الشعب الامريكي
مستعد ل- ليجاز بمدنه واراضيه لاجل نزاع
لا يتبع لهم كان هناك الكثير من النزاعات
السابقه التي تدخل بها
الشعب الامريكي وكانوا قد وقعوا هذا هذه
النزاعات علما ان هذه الاراضي الاراضي
روسيه همم معترف بها من همم عام 45 هل
مستعد الشعب الامريكي بالمجالفه والمخاطره
بالمواطنهم ومدنهم وانا اعتقد ان الشعب
الامريكي غير مستعد لهذا
وان يكرر عام 69 اذا كنتم سالتم الشعب
الامريكي الى قالوا اننا ليسنا مستعدين
نحن نعتمد على القوانين الدوليه التي
انشئت بالتعاون مع ال- اا الولايات
المتحده وهذه هي الاساسات للسلم
والاتفاقات السلميه
الرئيس الروسي اليوم كان واضحا عودته
لموضوع ان الغرب يسعى لاضعاف روسيا
وتفتيتها وهو امر كثيره ما كررت روسيا
وكانت هناك ضمانات قدمت من جانب ماكرون
ضمانات غربيه بان هذا لن يحدث ولكن العوده
لها في هذه المرحله الا يضعنا في المربع
الاول من جديد
من المستحيل الاتفاق مع اي جهه في اي نزاع
بعيدا عن القوانين الدوليه اي اتفاقات لا
تعتمد على القوانين التي تم انشائها
حتى يعم السلام هذا يعني اننا نقف على باب
معركه وحروب جديده لذلك في هذه الظروف نحن
مستعدين للتنازل ولكن الان بشرط ان لا
نتنازل عن اراضنا ومواقعنانا نحن ننظر على
ننظر لاكرانيا على انها منطقه مهمه للامن
الروسي ونطلب ان لا يتدخل احد في تلك
المناطق ونحن نستطيع ان نتفق بطريقه رائعه
مع الاداره الاخرانيه بشرط ان لا يستلموا
الاسلحه الامريكيه
في النهايه سيد هبس لدى روسيا مخاوف
استراتيجيه يعني هذا موقفها وهذا من حقها
واللجوء والحديث عن تقديم منظمه اييه
منظومه
للجانب الاوكراني الا يزيد من هذه المخاوف
لماذا الذهاب بهذا الاتجاه
يبرر العدوان يبرر سرقه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه يقول ان روسيا
ستقوم تنازلات السلامه
2014 وايضا وايضا المناطق اخرى شهر فبراير
هذا ليس السلام هذا هذا الغرام
هذا همم هذا الارقام القوي على الضعيف
وهذا لا يشخر قاعده للسلام اطلاقا طريقه
تحقيق السلام همم
التي احتلتها 2014 الى
ده اللي قراني هذا كان تحقق السلامه
بهذه الطريقه
من منطقه مؤخرا وهي ايضا تدافع عن
استراتيجيتها ولها مخاوف استراتيجييه
شاهدناها في كوبا الحديث عن قيام روسيا
بهذا في هذا الوقت بهذه الطريقه من الجانب
الاداره الامريكيه قد تعتبره موسكو مستفزا
ز
هل هذا السؤال انه يمكن يمكن
ذلك ولكن ليس في اي وقت من هذا العمليات
وتلك الاخطاء الامريكيه
امريكا على الاراضي غير اراضيها لو هذا
مقامت به روسيا في اوكرانيا همم
العالم كله يرى ذلك
انه اراضي روسيه هذا وراء هذا عدوان ويجب
ان نفهم ذلك
في المقابل ايضا موسكو ايضا تتلوح بصريخ
همم صارمر تتحدث عن
يعني ردع نووي كل هذا الا يعد ايضا صب
الزيت على النار
الروسيه كانت انشات في الستينات من
الاتحاد السوفيتي
وهذا فقط
للوقوف امام القوه النوويه الامريكيه وليس
هناك اي هدف منه اخرا لان
هناك صواريخ
النوويات في المناطق الامريكيه وتواريخنا
مواجهه ضدها
عام
1994 على اساس اتفاق موسكو اتفقنا على
ان
سوف نطور هذه الاسلحه
اذا ماده الولايات المتحده الاسلحه الى
المناطق التي تنتمي لنا الجميل الامريكي
يقول ان هذه المناطق ليس لنا همم ينظر الى
الوثائق ويتاكد ان اهم مناطق همم صوفيا
وقد انفصلت الاتحاد السوفيتي بطريقه غير
قانونيه
فليتخيل اذا كان اتخاذ انفصل عن امريكا
وماذا لو قامت امريكا بمحاوله اعادته هذه
المناطق بالطبع هذا حق امريكي وهذا نفس
الشيء همم الذي يحق لنا اعاده الاراضي
التي انفصلت عنها بطريقه غير قانونيه
اذا ما فعلا تم تزويد الطرفين بهذه
الاسلحه فمن هناك خطر كبير ان يتسع نطاق
الحرب وتذهب الى مستوى ابعد واخطر بكثير
مما هو حصل حاليا واسالك سيد هل هناك طرف
ثالث طرف امامي يمكن ان يتدخل في هذه
المرحله
لي- يعني يجعل فرص السلام اكثر او واقعيها
طريقه تحقيق السلام هي اعطاء اوكرانيا
السلاح للحاق الهزيمه بروسيا على الاراضي
اوكرانيا
الروسي يتحدث القانون الدولي لان روسيا
ضمنت اراضي
اوكرانيا عندما في معاهده بودابست في 1944
كما ان ابرمت معاهدات
بضمان الحدود الاقليميه
لاكرانيا
الدولي بشكل علني وزميلي فواتير مثل بوتين
ان يقدم تهديدات النوويه وهذا امر سخيف
سخيف وخطير وحتى
الصين رفضوا مثل هذه التهديدات
روسيا همم تهدد باحتمال استخدام
السلاح النووي اذا ما حتى في فيلندا
والسويد الى المتر
وللته حصل ذلك ولم يفعله اي شيء واضح ان
الاطراف تختلف على اسباب النزاع
ومساراته وكل طرف يعتبر الطرف الاخر يعني
ذهب الى ابعد احد في همم المجانبه الحقيقه
ولكن يبدو ان الطرفين يلتقيان فيما يتعلق
بالتشاؤم من فرص السلام في هذه المرحله
والسؤالك سيد صدره همم لما لا تقدم روسيا
ربما شئ من التنازل لتكسر الطريق على هذه
الحجه كما سمعنا جون كربي يقول انه لم
تظهر موسكو اي بادره او مؤشر على حسن
نحن مستعدين للتنازلات ولكن تعونا نتحدث
عن اي تنازلات هل نقدم لهم مناطق التابعه
لناس بالطبعنا مستعدين لهذا خاصه عندما
نتحدث عن اوكرانيا التي تتبع لنا حسب
الاتفاقات الدوليه كما قلت
[موسيقى]
قرارات الاعتراف
مستقلات كل هذا بنيه على وثائق غيرت
قانونيه لذلك هذه مناطق تابعه لنا ونحن
لست مستعددين لا نريد ان نحتلها او او ان
نديرها ولكنها الان نريد ان تهددنا نريد
ان تكون في درجه تؤمن الحدود الروسيه باي
طريقه
اشكرك همم
او يفقني في عضو مجلس ادومه الروسي واشكر
جون هيرز مسؤول لشؤون اوراسيا في وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه وسفير الامريكي السابق
لدى اوكرانيا واشكركم ايضا انتم مشاهدينا
الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه من ما وراء
الخبر
[موسيقى]